[Musique]
faire bouillir l'eau pour la boire c'est
le quotidien de plusieurs québécois dans
cette garderie en milieu familial de
lac-au-saumon dans le bas saint laurent
martin gagnon doit faire bouillir son
haut depuis 15 ans c'est un con c'est la
sinne richesse qu'on a de l'eau non
c'est important on en abondance mais on
peut pas la consommer 15 ans qu'elle n'a
pas d'eau potable qu'elle achète de
l'eau en bouteille pour sa garderie
chaque semaine pour faire bouillir l'eau
pour la consommer mais moi je la
consomme pas je l'achète
alors c'est beaucoup dessous parce que
on achète beaucoup d'eau au québec une
trentaine de municipalités ont des
problèmes de qualité d'eau potable
environ 12000 québécois sont touchés à
l'accouchement
on parle de 1000 personnes la grosse
problématique et de l'autre côté du lac
haut ce que les gens aucune déclaration
aucune infiltration l'eau est vraiment
non potable est un avis d'émulsion
constante pour l'ensemble du village
système de filtration est à refaire ils
ne respectent pas les normes du
gouvernement
c'est sûr que c'est une problématique
puis ça crée des incertitudes se crée
des inquiétudes au niveau de la
population
on les comprend partout au québec des
villages ont le même problème
selon les informations du ministère de
l'environnement à la martre en gaspésie
on doit faire bouillir l'eau depuis 18
ans à ward en montérégie depuis 11
ici à la durantaye près de québec ça
fait deux ans que la moitié de la
population n'a pas d'eau potable 400
résidents sont touchés le maire veut
régler le problème
comme plusieurs autres élus en région
c'est le système et si vous voulez
mettre à jour ce problème alors
exactement aux problèmes aux produits
dans l'environnement qui ne garantit pas
un traitement correct 24 heures sur 24
sept jours par semaine 12 mois par année
et ça signifie que des gens que pourrait
toucher des gens pour être touchés
pourraient être infectés par des
bactéries quelconque
aucun maire n'a oublié ce qui est arrivé
à walkerton en ontario en 2000
[Musique]
sept personnes sont mortes deux mille
autres ont été malades après avoir bu de
l'eau contaminés à la bactérie e.coli
j'ai eu une épisode où ce que les gens
ne pouvaient même plus se laver les
mains à l'intérieur parce qu'on était à
6 ans de colis et plus pendant plusieurs
semaines donc on est en situation
d'urgence
à l'école primaire de lac-au-saumon on
prend la situation au sérieux dont
m'assurer d'avoir 25 à 30 bouteilles
pleines à chaque deux semaines alors que
si on va sur le mur le directeur doit
s'assurer que les élèves ne boivent pas
l'eau des abreuvoirs de l'école avec mon
généreux qui est là qui s'assure que les
jeunes s'en vont directement à l'endroit
de l'eau qui prennent pas de l'eau parce
que leurs bouteilles d'eau et à l'état
dans leur classe pourtant le
gouvernement des programmes pour aider
les municipalités à se doter
d'infrastructures d'eau potable moderne
à l'accouchement où on tente de régler
le problème depuis des années on déplore
que le gouvernement n'a juste pas plus
rapidement les délais on demande
toujours où il ya toujours des nouvelles
normes qui apparaît ce cas qu'on envoie
les documents au ministère
ça peut prendre j'ai déjà eu jusqu'à un
délai d'un an avant de recevoir des
nouvelles ça fait quand même dix huit
ans maintenant que le dossier est en
marche on n'a pas encore de solution
on n'est pas encore en projet final fait
que oui on est oubliés
c'est notre avis d'ébullition pour le
maire de la durantaye québec doit
presser le pas il ya des volontés qui
doivent des volontés politiques qui
doivent s'intensifier là dessus comme
peu de cette municipalité on n'a pas des
revenus
attaque aussi de nous aider pour de
régler le dossier de l'eau potable pour
s'assurer pour rassurer nos citoyens à
la fédération des municipalités
on est préoccupé par le problème pour
son président il en va de la survie des
villages on n'accepte pas d'agrandir un
village j'te pas d'eau potable
des fois tu manques 2/3 de trois
résidences de plus qui fait que ton en
écoles resteraient en vie plutôt que la
ferme et les résidents de lac-au-saumon
eux continuent de recevoir chaque mois
des avis d'ébullition d'eau on la
regarde mais c'est toujours la même soit
c'est qu'à mourir l'homme comme dan ce
martin gagnon rêve du jour où les
enfants de sa garderie pour en boire
l'eau du robinet
[Musique]